what are we baking today storm we're
making cupcakes
we're making cupcakes yeah um just go
ahead and call your dentist now
cause kylie jenner just shared a video
of her and her baby girl making cupcakes
together
and the whole thing is so sweet it's
giving us
a toothache thank you kylie gifted us
with
yet another baking tutorial on youtube
complete with her sous chef her
two-year-old daughter stormy to
celebrate the launch of her new kylie by
grinch holiday makeup collection
okay so now we have our beautiful green
grinch cupcakes ready to decorate
yeah we want to keep that green kylie
and her mini me rock matching grinch pjs
while they decorate some grinch cupcakes
and stormy
she's kylie's tiny little hype woman
she's
got this mommy thank you so much i love
you more
you feel bigger i'm so beautiful
oh my god our hearts just grew three
sizes
and what happened then well in whoville
they say
that the grinch's small heart grew
three sizes that day
so to be fair kylie did most of the work
what are you saying thank you mommy but
stormy she did what kids do
she snacked on all the candy i tried to
eat a mommy
you wanna try to eat it yeah did you try
to eat it whoa
what does it taste like it's like
crunky and kylie she did what moms do
i love the heart you added thank you
thanked her kid for the effort and undid
what her kid did
i love your heart but i'm gonna take it
off okay
thank you you're welcome of course this
isn't the first time kylie and stormy
have whipped up some
over-the-top cuteness in the kitchen are
you excited
whoa whoa
you're the best type woman storm yeah or
a hype baby
back in october the mommy daughter duo
decorated some halloween cookies
and no one was more pumped about it than
stormy
i did it pour it on in baby okay mommy
what whoa it and let's
mix it together
[Music]
i love how excited you are about the
cookies are you ready to see our cookies
how cute let's
eat this still not convinced stormy's
the cutest kid on the planet
wait for it i love making cookies with
you
mommy and my heart is mush
say bye to that camera